et je sais qu'il ya du micro trottoir on
démarre par quoi on va démarrer dans
plein de choses après infection prime
sur ces huit femmes c'est un cauchemar
[Rires]
[Musique]
rappelez vous il ya quelques temps je
venais vous voir avec les images de
jacky 1 l'animateur phare d'idf1 qu'ils
avaient trouvé une technique sympa pour
adorer allah pour désamorcer les vannes
pourries cousin dingle essuie glace avec
ses droits bell a dû se rendre compte
que c'est un peu chiant pour les invités
du coup il a changé de jingle non je
déconne c'est le même en plus bas tard
comment appelle-t-on foot enceinte
attaque sautée bon continuer à renforcer
sur glace soit deux mois pour mal je
suis resté sur cette émission ils ont eu
la chance de recevoir un acteur de
classe internationale un mec qui joue
dans une série française que tout le
monde connaît qu'un cv comme ça
heureusement il sait le mettre en valeur
son cv écoutez bien c'est impressionnant
je suis d'accord et la spécialité de
jackie selebi interview il a clairement
très bien préparé ces questions qui est
très pertinent sur wii alors je suis né
à lier le cojep a choisi et jacky c'est
surtout quelqu'un avec le coeur sur la
main qui sait mettre ses invités en
valeur toujours plus de la catégorie
djamen de bourges florence foresti
c'est-à-dire un reer pour les 30
secondes
ton servir tous deux ont d'ailleurs fait
d'être autant j'adore ce besoin de toi
lanceurs n'ont eu que des folies connais
rien à ça
12h48 alors je préviens la région
passera au magnéto sur monsieur castaldi
injuste après voilà parce que j'ai
regardé ses news
et je suis je suis tombé sur eux je suis
tombé sur benjamin castaldi qui étaient
sur place et qui faisait un petit peu sa
promo qui abordait ses projets d'avenir
notamment ce qui sera demain déjà il
sera devant après une navigation sûre
c'est vite et après il y aura balances
ton post est gay sera en direct en plus
avec kelly sera leur premier prix
mention d'un bêtisier spécial couples et
on prépare une émission ensemble ou on
va s'affronter sur des épreuves c'est ça
justement il voyait un peu plus loin
j'ai parlé de ce prime vous allez vous
affrontez alors je tiens à vous rassurer
cyril vous pouvez tout de suite signé
avec benjamin castaldi
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment renseigné sur ses projets
d'avenir six nations il y en a qu il ya
un programme qui va me faire beaucoup
réponse à écrire on veut faire une fugue
de duels lui lui lui contre moi sur une
dizaine d'épreuves et ça a déjà été fait
ça n'ont jamais non pourquoi vous a pas
été fait non mais oui ça a été fait là
bas ça va on va peut-être leur faire et
pour illustrer ses propos benjamin a
utilisé une métaphore pas du tout
malaise entre pour une émission diffusée
à 11 heures et a eu qu à challans ya eu
la fête sur le parvis notre dame pour le
polisario
ouais bah oui mais vous savez avec avec
de la patience et du saindoux un
éléphant paie l'impôt mais malaise et on
sent qu'il ya comme une petite rivalité
entre jean marc et belgique mais c'est
bon enfant
aujourd'hui vous avez vu camille combal
qui est parti sur téva ce que vous
auriez aimé être à sa place
j'ai refusé mois danse avec les stars je
les refuse et il nous tarde fait à
l'époque avec avec flavie comme candidat
non comme pourrait castaldi a continué
sa tournée des médias est en chemin je
crois qu'il a pris froid et ça se voit
qu'ils aient un passé avec avec tf1
évidemment qu'ils s'entendent pas comme
larrons en foire pas se mentir mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entendez moi juste alors vous avez un
mot longtemps possible castaldi et ce à
quoi sa mère qui sont plantés dit des
bêtises et la carotte
bien sûr je vais dans le rugby français
comme vous le savez l'espèce animale est
en danger du coup je suis allé demander
aux français s'ils sentaient concernés
par la question alors globalement oui
malheureusement c'est au moment où je
leur demande s'ils sont prêts à
s'engager que là ça se dégonfle un petit
peu quoi comme vous le savez de nos
jours le climat se détraque un petit peu
ce qui fait que les animaux perdre leur
habitat naturel
oui est ce que vous vous sentez concerné
par la question oui pas je trouve ça
regrettable
est-ce que selon vous va vous pensez
qu'il est temps d'agir agissons agissent
est ce que vous seriez prête à agir pour
aider les animaux n'est bien sûr pas bon
et bien vous allez pouvoir vous allez
justement parce qu'on cherche en fait à
non non non
ah non non non non une famille d'accueil
en fait à ces serpents de bornéo non
alors voilà en fait il faudrait les
prendre chez vous quelques jours sur la
piste je suis déjà engagé dans pas mal
d'associations bat alors vous allez
pouvoir nous aider justement c'est des
araignées de bornéo on leur cherche une
famille d'accueil jusqu'à l'aube sinon
j'ai pas j'ai peur des araignées
non non je sais pas il faudrait les
prendre chez vous quelques jours non
content d'annoncer ce n'est pas vous
avez dit vous étiez prête à vous engager
pour les animaux n'est pas avec ça non
non c'est tout paraît banal et du brésil
ils ont une petite famille d'opter pour
le passage par de dommages prends
l'avion demain
cyril jeu cyril je t'aime bien j'en
garde tes pmp mais les furets on s'en
fout les furets on s'en tape
voilà